i do like those teams that stan pat and
let the market reset and the teams that
resign their own players i absolutely
love what the tampa bay buccaneers have
done so far in re-signing their own
players i think it gives them the best
chance mike to repeat
yeah let's talk about the tampa bay
buccaneers we knew that number one they
are keeping chris godwin via the
franchise tag so they have their top
receivers number two they sign levante
david to a two-year deal he'll be next
to devon white for the next two seasons
and then once they give devin white a
big payday that's probably when levante
david goes elsewhere unless he takes a
lot less and now today just after noon
eastern one of the first moves that was
announced and obviously this one
involves no
illegal tampering although it does
here's what i believe happened when we
saw the news that shaq barrett is
staying with the buccaneers right as the
clock struck 12 my interpretation and
others in league circles agree with me
on this
the bucks had an offer
on the table for shaq barrett shaq
barrett through his agent drew rosenhaus
had shot that offer to all other teams
and they knew what else was out there
and the buccaneers made it clear
the moment 12 o'clock eastern rolls
around on monday march 15 if you don't
take this we're going to start calling
other agents who represent other pass
rushers and we're going to use that
money on them and this offer is going to
be gone and i think that's why barrett
took it when he took it because there is
every year urgency we got to know what
you're going to do because if you're not
going to take this we're moving on to
the next guy and for the bucks plan a
was keep shaq barrett we got to know
what you're going to do and if you're
not going to do it we're moving on to
plan b and with so many pass rushers
this year shireen by 12 30 12 45 1
o'clock the offer would have been off
the table for shaq barrett and maybe the
bucks would have had two guys to come in
and fill the void created by barrett's
departure
and you alluded to this mike when the
bucks franchised chris godwin that they
likely were going to sign shaq barrett
to a long-term deal and that's exactly
what happened so it was huge of them to
keep both godwin and shaq barrett which
i didn't know that they would be able to
do i didn't know if they would be able
to do that but we both said shaq barrett
is the most important player the bucks
need to keep and if they don't keep him
they've obviously got to go out
somewhere and find a pass rush he had
four sacks in their last two games
that's the nfc championship game in the
super bowl he also had eight quarterback
pressures so he was huge to that defense
and a reason i'm not sure the bucks win
the super bowl without shaq barrett in
the way he played in those last two
games so it was crucial for them to keep
him or to find a replacement or two as
past rushers to replace him but huge
that they were able to keep him mike
that's not the full band being kept
together though that's just barrett and
david and godwin
they still have work to do
leonard fournette what's he going to do
running backs don't get paid a ton of
money in free agency and he's kind of a
part-time guy now if in tampa ronald
jones is the the other guy they've gone
back and forth as to who the top guy is
in that backfield but if another team
says we want to make leonard fournette
our workhorse
you'll wait and you see if that offer
comes in and that would be the kind of
thing that could get fernet to leave
then you have to see what ndamukong soo
is going to do
and then there's gronk
i thought if gronk plays for anybody
he's playing for the buccaneers and and
staying attached to the hip with tom
brady but gronk said on the kyle brant
podcast that
he's going to dip his toe in a free
agency and see what's out there and he's
got every right to do that and i don't
know what the best fit for gronk is from
a football standpoint i think las vegas
is the ideal fit from a lifestyle
standpoint but uh interesting to see
who who else takes that seriously and
makes a real offer for gronk because
it's one thing for gronk to say i'm
going to see what else is out there it's
another thing
for teams that are out there to take
that as a serious indication he'd leave
and not just a way for him to leverage
the bucks to pay more
i'm going to be surprised mike if he
leaves tom brady in the tampa buccaneers
i just think he sees that as his best
chance to win another championship which
is really important to him and to play
another season with tom brady so going
to be really surprised i i think he's
probably just trying to get more out of
the bucks now i don't know if the bucks
have more to spend right because they've
already spent a huge chunk of change now
franchise tagging uh chris godwin and
signing re-signing shaq barrett so
there's only so much money to go around
so maybe they don't come to an agreement
simply based on money but i think
there's more important things to gronk
than money and i think he showed that
coming back and playing this year with
tom brady because i truly do think he
was retired and
planning to stay retired until the
opportunity came to rejoin tom brady
with the buccaneer so i you know i think
he ends up staying there but it is
interesting that he's going to test the
market supposedly mike
i i don't think he's going to find
anything significant out there he was
used primarily as a blocker for most of
the season he was running in mud for
most of the season part of me wonders
based upon
how spry he was in super bowl 55 whether
it was some sort of a rope-a-dope but
he's not the guy that he was a few years
ago he's not going to get huge money in
free agency and he has a very specific
and narrow role which entails
just using him judiciously most of the
year and ramping up his
involvement when the playoffs roll
around otherwise he's going to get
injured we've seen that time and again
so i think it's going to be the bucks or
no one i thought that also for antonio
brown we haven't heard anything about
him remember there were other teams last
year that were tied to brown russell
wilson has clamored for brown in the
past in seattle and now that the josh
gordon thing seems to be over and done
maybe they pivot back to brown the
ravens from time to time will clamor for
brown i think dez bryant was the ravens
way of creating a peace offering to the
locker room last year when guys like
lamar jackson and hollywood brown
antonio brown's cousin were politicking
for him to join the team and then the
packers get tied to brown from time to
time so i don't think that's
a 100 done deal that he plays for the
bucks or no one in 2021 now that he's
got a ring and now that he's kind of
stabilized himself the question becomes
is there another place he can go and be
successful and be more involved
especially with them keeping chris
godwin around that that keeps antonio
brown down on the depth chart the
challenge though is shireen to have a
quarterback who has that same svengali
or if you prefer sven jolly influence
on antonio brown that tom brady did
because tom brady the first guy
really since mike tomlin before we knew
what a problem antonio brown can be to
get through to him and keep him from
giving in to his
his uh
inclinations that could cause trouble
for him and for others
yeah no question about it mike tom brady
is a calming influence on a b we saw
that as mac tomlin was so again another
one i think ultimately ends up back with
tampa because i just don't think he's
going to find a market like he thinks
he's going to find the market for his
services i mean we saw that last year
tampa was his best option last year but
you know mike who might be the most
important guy for the bucks now to keep
is ryan's suck-up right because they
have depth at receiver they have depth
that tied in they don't have another
kicker and we know the kicking problems
they have through the years and they
solved it this year with ryan suck up
they need to make sure they resign this
guy
or they could just use a second round
pick on a kicker that works out well
when the buccaneers do that right trade
up
get a kicker that way by the way this
kendrick bourne thing is confusing and
this is what happens when somebody
reports something on twitter and
somebody else tries to repurpose it and
they do it maybe not 100 accurately
bourne isn't done with the patriots yet
it's talking to the patriots and others
according to espn so it may not be that
the patriots will be signing someone
else while we're still on the air today
and remember none of these deals are
official until four o'clock eastern on
wednesday the players can back out the
teams can back out the most significant
one that comes to mind for me is frank
gore several years back had a deal with
the eagles and then said no thanks went
to the colts instead now that creates
hard feelings but
yeah and it's a bad look it's a bad look
for the agent especially oh anthony barr
did the same thing i forgot about that
he was going to the jets he backed out
it's not done till it's done but at
least for now all of these deals are
being reported shireen as if they're
done and and i feel like if we don't
issue the caveat that's when we walk
right into the the the the doorway that
hits us in the face and one of these
deals falls apart
yeah we had the michael brocker's deal
last year too that was really weird but
i think it was the ravens pulling out of
that one right because they couldn't do
the the physical and all that he ended
up going back to the rams
last year so yeah these deals aren't
done until they're done and they're not
quite done yet mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports